. Let me ask you a question.
What do you think is the real corona virus
death toll?
It appears it could be more than 54 thousand
deaths higher than the official death toll.
And I'm going to explain how the CDC data
points us to that conclusion in a second.
But at least to start, theoretically, anytime
you have something as big as a pandemic which
infects more than five million people in the
United States, where it 5.2 million official
cases to a country of more than 330 million
people, people die every day for corona virus
and other reasons.
There are co morbidities.
There are other factors.
It's going to be unlikely that the official
death toll is exactly what the real death
toll is for the virus.
Now, on the one side, there are conspiracy
theories from the right that are about deception
and politics, where they say the real death
toll is much lower.
It's not 166 thousand.
It's much smaller.
They claim this is not me.
This is the arguments some on the right make.
A lot of deaths are being counted as coronavirus
and they're really not.
And they'll talk about someone died in a car
crash and a hospital counted.
It is coronavirus because they get more money
that way or whatever, or Democrats are lying
and blowing up the death rate in order to
make political points or whatever the case
may be.
Now, you should be skeptical of that theory.
And indeed, there's no evidence for that theory
other than if you want to be anecdotal.
There might be cases where it's not a car
accident.
But, you know, it's an infection caused by
a comorbidity in an elderly person who had
corona virus.
And maybe there's like some debate as to should
this or shouldn't this count as a corona virus
death.
But these are small numbers of situations
in a country with 5.2 million infections.
You're bound to have some anecdotes like that.
But on the other side, there's a much more
compelling reason to think the real corona
virus death toll is dramatically higher than
the official.
And it is something called excess deaths.
The number of extra deaths during the March
to July period suggests that more than 54000
additional people have died of coronavirus
be above and beyond the official death toll.
This is derived when you look at excess deaths
and in the United States because we have so
many people and so many years of data and
such detailed statistics about disease.
We know how many people on average will die
of all causes based on our population, based
on what's called the normal amount of death.
We know, okay, if you add up expected car
accident deaths, cancer deaths, heart disease,
flu altogether, we know when you don't have
a pandemic how many people typically die.
And if you look at the deaths we would expect
from March 15th to July 25th.
You see that during those dates.
There were almost 200, 1000 excess deaths,
deaths beyond what we would normally have.
And during that time, the official coronavirus
death toll was only 140, 7000.
That leaves about 54000 extra deaths not officially
attributed to coronavirus.
Now, epidemiologists favor looking at excess
deaths to gauge the impact of a pandemic because
excess deaths don't depend on testing people
and knowing exactly who had the virus.
Posthumous testing, testing when someone goes
into the hospital, et cetera.
And indeed, when you look at excess deaths,
everything tracks consistently with this theory.
If you look at where the excess deaths disproportionately
are, it's in the states hardest hit by corona
virus.
And it is a very coherent story that excess
death analysis points us do.
So in all likelihood, the real coronavirus
death toll right now is at least 54000 deaths
higher than the original one.
It's even more because that was March 15 to
July 25.
In the two weeks since July 25, we've had
a resurgence in deaths and in all likelihood,
there are more uncounted deaths during that
period.
So what is the likely real coronavirus death
toll?
Remember, official is 166.
It's probably somewhere around 225 to 235.
And rapidly approaching 250000 deaths.
We are going to have to accept that the death
toll is much higher than many think.
When the pandemic is so widespread, when tests
are still today taking five to seven days
or longer to come back with results, we know
we aren't capturing all the cases and therefore
it follows.
We're not capturing all the deaths either.
We later will have to see what is the long
term impact on the lungs, on the heart, on
other systems from having and recovering from
corona virus.
Because you could have a situation where years
down the line, there are premature deaths
caused by damage done to vital organs by corona
virus.
We don't know the extent of that yet.
That's something the medical community is
looking at.
Any deaths are tragic.
We have many unnecessary deaths due to the
failed Trump response.
But we also just have to face the reality
that by now we probably have somewhere between
55 and 60000 deaths that are not in the official
death count, which are due to corona virus,
which gets us to what happens in November.
And how is the right trying to get themselves
reelected despite Donald Trump's failed response?
Let's talk about that next